- Mit dieser Maschine machen wir heute
die Fassadenreinigung.
Komm mal her!
Einmal das blaue Kabel
[den blauen Schlauch],
der ist für das neutralisierte Wasser
und kommt hier rein.
Und das ist das schwarze Kabel
[der schwarze Schlauch],
der ist für „Chemie“, der kommt an
den zweiten Adapter dran.
Das wird so gebaut.
Und die Schnur [der Klettverschluss]
muss immer so gedreht werden,
damit das Kabel [der Schlauch]
nicht hin- und hergeht.
Jannik, dreh mal bitte das Wasser auf.
Laufen lassen, einmal hier starten.
Nur am Knopf drehen,
und jetzt geht’s los.
Kürzen wir ab, Jannik. Abkürzen.
Also, es wird immer abgekürzt, wenn wir
die Hälfte der Fenster gemacht haben.
Einmal danach kurz runterdrehen.
Einmal zum Ausmachen den Knopf drücken,
dass das Gerät aus ist. Okay.
- Und dann die Flüssigkeit auf den Mopp.
Das Wasser ein bisschen nachfüllen.
Und dann schön auf die Fassade einreiben.
Wenn du möchtest, kannst du
es ja auch mal machen.
Genau so.
- Jetzt nimmst du die zweite Variante.
Ein bisschen Chemie auf den Schwamm.
Das, was da noch geblieben ist,
kriegst du damit weg.
- Auf den Schwamm drauf.
Tust noch mehr drauf, genau, richtig so.
Genau.
Vielleicht versuchst du mal kreisende
Bewegungen - warte mal -
kreisende Bewegungen ...
kreisende Bewegungen sind besser,
dass es auch schön in die Poren reingeht.
Siehst du?
Siehst du noch etwas?
Lass mich noch mal dran bitte.
Ja, so, jetzt ist der Arbeitsvorgang
beendet, wir sind fertig.